do you have the next great idea but
don't know how to build it check out the
product design course developed by
Google and Udacity to learn the basics
of developing your idea into a
marketable product design your first
product faster than you might think
without fancy tools and thousands of
dollars in this course you'll design and
prototype and test your ideas you'll
also design mock-ups
to communicate your idea and capture
metrics to support your growth this
course uses the methodology that Google
venture uses with their startups to get
them moving quickly and easily start
creating today for more information
visit udacity.com/google